you go through the entire first level
and nothing happens
but the whole time you're waiting for
somebody to jump out of a door at you
nothing happens then you go to the next
level it's the same giant hallway and
you start walking by then all of a
sudden you hear a noise behind you
what has to happen in the first 10
minutes of a horror screenplay
back in the day they used to say
when they would pick up a horror movie
distributors that you had to have a kill
in the first five minutes of your horror
movie that was a requirement so most of
the time because you want something to
hook the audience you want to get them
in being like this is what this movie's
going to be about
a movie like scream does that really
really well by having this whole like
nice happy
seeing and then killing the biggest
actor in the movie which was from psycho
albert hitchcock psycho you have a whole
opening sequence with this high-end
actress
and then they kill her and then the
movie starts and it's like
that's a little more than five minutes
but in screaming was five minutes
you need something big a big inciting
incident like that to hook the audience
in and be like okay this is the ride
we're in for
and i think that's important i mean
that's important with every movie you
have to have something to hook them at
the beginning to be able to bring them
in and if you start off with a very slow
sequence in the beginning and your
audience starts to nod off 20 minutes in
that's a problem you know you don't want
that to happen so
usually try to start with a bang
and end with a bigger bang i think
yeah i know with children of the corn
that was pretty gruesome that was
actually too gruesome for me but with
carrie i don't remember within the first
five ten minutes it was kind of a slow
build it is a slow build but it was
still very effective harry is much more
like a giallo type style like an italian
style of a slow lots of reds lots of
deep colors
um
which is a big fan base for for sure and
there's definitely different types of
genres of horror i think that you kind
of
can look at
i mean there's slasher is a genre and
giallo is a genre
there's comedy horror there's action
horror it's really interesting about the
comedy horror is you look back again to
the great depression
and comedy horror came in then when they
started introducing abbot and costello
meets frankenstein because the world was
on fire and everyone was depressed so
they're like okay we got to bring movies
back in
that can raise spirits to kind of get
people's minds off of this they started
introducing those comedy movies
with the fans of of the monsters at the
time
and so that kind of helped and that's
happened too that happened in the 80s as
well with the horror where it started
off strong strong slashers and then by
the end of the 80s
freddy krueger is a joke and he's making
one-liners and the movies are funny and
they have
like movies like student bodies which is
a spoof of slasher movies then scream
ends up coming out in the 90s which is
basically a spoof of slasher movies as
it is just told a little bit more
seriously and then that got its own
spoof and scary movie which they made
five of
so
it kind of goes in hand hand in hand
horror and comedy
but you want that roller coaster you
know you want to have the tension
of of
running for your life and then the humor
where it's like oh
oh we survived we're okay he made a joke
okay now i feel better and i'm good and
that's like oh oh oh that's back up and
that's back down so that's the overall
hope i guess
what about in japan they had a 10-year
10-year depression
did what kind of movies
i actually have no idea yeah okay i'm
just curious if it followed a similar um
and there's their movies are very
spiritual you know everything's a spirit
a lot of spirit-based demon based
um
japanese horror is very specific
which is cool it's very
it's very in tuned we went to japan for
our 10th anniversary
and one of the things we did was we went
to this
this incredible theme park called fuji q
which is the base of mount fuji and in
it is the world's biggest haunted house
it is four stories tall it's a it's a
hospital it's a massive fully sized
hospital
and you walk in and they tell you all
your instructions in japanese i have no
idea what they were saying
and then they're like okay goodbye and
they slam the door and they told us it
lasts 45 minutes
and i was like how on earth does it take
45 minutes to walk through a haunted
house and so you go in
and it's literally an abandoned hospital
and you go to a hallway there's a room
full of doors and every door is slightly
cracked open there's like 30 doors in
front of you
and the lights are flickering but you
find out really quickly something i've
never seen before in a haunted house and
one of the this is definitely the best
haunted house experience i've ever had
it's soundproofed
so when you get into the hallway all you
hear
is your heart beating
you hear nothing it's like a vacuum and
you're like
you usually hear that like blast music
and they blast sounds and everything and
there's you're in a line with 100 people
nothing and so all of a sudden they're
like okay go ahead and you have to get
out of this hospital and so you start
walking down this long 50-foot hallway
longer than that 100-foot hallway really
and you walk down it you're peeking into
each door and you're like all right my
wife's like close and it's just you and
your party so just my wife and i walking
through this entire thing
and you walk around you go through the
entire first level and nothing happens
but the whole time you're waiting for
somebody to jump out of a door at you
nothing happens then you go to the next
level it's the same giant hallway and
you start walking by then all of a
sudden you hear a noise behind you
and you turn around and you see a guy
just standing in the middle of the
hallway staring at you like zombified
just staring
and it's just you too in this big empty
hallway and this dude
and then all of a sudden he starts
screaming at the top of his lungs
and he runs at you at full sprint and so
of course my wife is gone like she's
taken off and i'm still looking to see
what's going on and so we start you
start running down this hallway and he
is right on your heels
like he's screaming at you and you get
to the end of the hallway and you turn
around and he's gone
and then you're like we have 30 more
minutes in this building
and you go through all these other
little things and it was crazy but i was
like wow what an experience it was so
nuts and i'd never experienced anything
like that before not in american haunted
houses so that was pretty neat wow
that sounds fun and you can build a lot
of creepiness in your own mind by
yourself with nothing around you so
we're kind of
subconsciously we're accustomed to how
fear works it's like okay someone's
gonna jump out of that door or oh this
light's gonna flicker this thing's gonna
happen that's probably what's gonna be
you know people try to walk these
haunted houses and call out everything
you go to like halloween horror nights
or something and like well that guy's
gonna be over there and then he is and
it's like oh
but that was a really interesting
experience for sure
oh that's really cool
i like that and it's about suspense it
sounds like more than anything oh yeah
yeah i mean you
i mean you're of course going you only
have one way to go so you're not really
making too many decisions while you're
stuck in this haunted house
but you literally all you hear is your
heart beating because like a vacuum and
so here's like
and you've been running around and so
now then you gotta go upstairs and they
have they had certain things that would
like run mechanics so you'd walk by
something they would just go boom and
just slam right next to you
and there's nothing there other than a
little mechanical thing and it'd be like
oh my gosh it was awesome that sounds
fun
i like that should something scary
happen on page one of a horror
screenplay or is it better to just
stretch it out a little farther
i don't think this should happen on page
one i think tension is really important
and i think building
in a horror especially you build your
location
and you build your characters
and you build your tension
i remember there's a great story about
in
i'm pretty sure it's the first alien
i can't remember it's alien or aliens
now but there's a whole scene of the
spaceship waking up
at the beginning of the movie
it's just the empty hallways and the
lights turning on of the spaceship like
introducing this dramatic arena that
we're getting ready to experience
and i always thought that was really
important towards that you you build
you want your stories to build and build
and build
and so
as far as something scary happening in
the very first page it would have to be
like an immediate
slam or something and and i think movies
will use gimmicks like that we're just
like boom there's a loud noise because
it's going to startle you because you're
in the theater with
bass and surround sound you're like
because it's
it's there but
i don't necessarily think it should be
on the first page but by page
five
you kind of want your audience to know
what they're in for
to give them a little piece of how to
expect what's going on
because i i like ramping things like
starting off and going up and up and up
and you have little divots and you go up
and up and up and then end
so i think that's important too
um
i also think people are scared by
different things like if you have
someone cutting someone's throat and
opening shot someone might be like
someone might be scared by that i
wouldn't be scared by it it's like oh
well that sucks for that person or it's
just gross or it's gory
but it's not really scary
i feel like the ultimate fear is is when
you feel your heart start to pound over
the tension and the music and the
moments and everything's building up and
you know something's gonna happen
and you're baiting the audience to get
to a certain point to then you can you
know slam it in or distract them and
they're kind of like oh that's a good oh
and then it comes out like two seconds
later and it solves them because they're
not
they're not fully prepared
um
but every movie is different too it i
think it kind of depends on what what
exactly the script calls for and the
vibe the movie has and
kind of what direction you want to go in